kim kardashian puts pete davidson to the
ultimate boyfriend test can kim rely on
you to capture her good side you have to
right know your angle the selfie queen
posted a vacay dump to ig on monday and
along with some self-shot snaps kim
handed over the camera to her man i was
like why not and from the looks of it
kim approves a peaceful talk skill she
wrote he passed the content taking
boyfriend test yes
the s l alum snapped a series of photos
of the skimp's founder posing in a sexy
black bikini showing off her washboard
abs while frolicking in the sand
looks like keat has been having a blast
on their romantic getaway here's the
pair packing on the pda in paradise and
kayaking in the clear blue ocean if it's
not good lighting then you do the more
moody vibe kim proved just that with
this pic a moody moment she shot a pete
shirtless and enjoying those tropical
views it's always so much fun this is
just the latest in a string of
relationship making moments from this
pair which kim's been opening up about
on the family's hulu show we're doing
really really good pete said i'm gonna
grow on you just just wait he's like
you're you're gonna
he knew he's like i give it four months
in and you're gonna be obsessed and i
was like oh
we'll
see don't know if that's any of your
business a source told e.t the pair has
had a strong connection since the
beginning but kim was cautious about
introducing her kids to pete mainly
because she didn't know if things were
moving in a serious direction i text him
i wasn't even thinking like oh my god
i'm gonna be in a relationship with him
i was just thinking like
heard about this bde need to get out
there like i need to just like
jump start my
i was just basically dtf but just like
pete's aced the boyfriend test he also
made a good impression on kim's four
kids what's your favorite thing about
him he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just hang
out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
[Laughter]
our e.t source added the kids and pete
get along very well and kim seeing him
be so great with them only made her fall
in love with pete moore what do you all
love about pete what are your favorite
things about him i love that he's
kind
and really really thoughtful he's the
most thoughtful person
and i love
yeah and i love the chemistry that kim
and him have together it's really sweet
i thought you said the chemistry i was
like okay chemistry chemistry
[Music]
[Music]
you